Hey, Vsauce. Michael here.
Our atmosphere
is a thin vail of air, held to earth's surface
by gravity.
We live in it, we breathe it, we walk through it
every day; it contains all weather, but yet
it is almost nothing.
In fact,
if the earth was the size of an apple
our atmosphere from the ground all
the way to outer space
would only be about as thick
as the skin of an apple.
And because our atmosphere gets
thinner, exponentially as you go up,
90 percent of our atmospheres mass
at this scale could fit within a space
as thin as just a
third of an apple's skin.
But that shrimpy sliver of a peel
would still be thousands of times
thicker than you are tall.
We humans are itsy bitsy dots
strolling around in a skinny sky.
But that skinny sky does a lot.
Think about this.
What if I had a really awesome big straw
and I stuck one end in the ocean and the other end out
in space.
Would outer space be able to suck
all the water out?
We know that
naked exposed veneer vacuum of space
all non concealed gases in your body
would be violently farted and burped
out. Sucked out.
But sucking is not attractive.
Instead, sucking merely refers to a flow
from a region of higher pressure to a
region of lower pressure.
In other words, a vacuum cleaner in and
of itself does not
attract matter to itself.
Like I said in my video
with no title, if you were to turn on a vacuum cleaner
at sea level,
a region inside the cleaner becomes as
thin as air in Denver, Colorado.
External
air, which is at a greater pressure,
is then literally pushed
by its own greater pressure into the machine, bringing
dust and debris with it.
The point is,
the strength of the force pushing air
into a vacuum cleaner
can only be as strong as the pressure
of the surrounding air.
Here on earth,
using a vacuum cleaner or even a space straw,
that pressure is
atmospheric pressure.
At sea level about 15 pounds per square inch
or 65.4 Newton's.
That amount of force can
only push pure water up about 10.3 meters
or 33.9 feet.
Because outer space
is not 10 meters up,
it's more like 100,000 meters up,
a space straw would be a terrible
doomsday device for a super villain to
use to get rid of our oceans.
Our atmosphere just isn't heavy or strong enough
to push water into orbit.
Because the weight
of air above, pushing molecules below in
all directions is responsible for
air pressure, air lowered down exerts
more pressure. The air at your feet
pushes with a slightly greater force
than the
air at your head. Now, across the human
body, you can't tell the difference.
But if an object is light enough,
it can be affected by this difference,
which is why a helium balloon floats.
The air down here pushes a tiny bit more
strongly than the air up here,
and since the balloon is lighter than
the same volume of air, it's literally
pushed up
by the air more strongly than gravity pulls it down.
This upward force, caused by a surrounding fluid
or gas that counteracts an object's weight,
is known as buoyancy.
Now, here on the surface of the earth,
the buoyancy of air isn't enough to
cause humans to float away
or be lifted. But it exists.
In fact, in a perfect vacuum,
you would weigh about a fifth of pound
more than you do
right now.
Thanks air! Back to our balloon
friend.
He's not going to float up forever
in the outer space, escaping earth.
Eventually, as the atmosphere thins out,
and the baloon expands, it will
pop and fall back down to earth,
its helium spreading throughout the atmosphere.
So, besides rockets that we intentionally
launch off of Earth, does our atmosphere ever
lose anything?
Does earth ever lose anything?
Does Earth ever gain anything?
I mean, I used to be smaller, I used to be a little kid.
But all of the atoms and molecules in my
body right now simply came from things
that I
consumed.
Things that I ate or drank or breathed in.
When new kids are born, the earth doesn't get
heavier, because a new baby is just a rearrangement of
atoms and molecules that used to be inside its mother
or molecules that she ate, drank or breathed in,
all of which came from earth.
Everything's recycled,
so is the earth not gaining or losing mass?
Well to begin, earth does lose some stuff.
For instance, hydrogen and helium are a bit too light
to stick around because of earth's
gravity. They eventually fly out into
space or get picked off by solar wind
at the edge of our atmosphere,
which is why, as I've said before,
we are likely to one day run out
of helium. Pretty soon.
But the earth gains mass in some ways as well.
For instance,
every year it's been estimated that 10 to 20
million kilograms of space dust
and meteorite fragments fall to Earth,
making it heavier. Now, if you factor in
the energy that the earth radiates away,
which is equivalent to mass, as well as
the energy the earth gets from the Sun
and holds onto, for instance,
using its greenhouse gases,
in total it has been calculated that every
year earth becomes 50 million kilograms
lighter.
That might sound like a lot,
but it is only 0.00 0000 0000 0000
1 percent of Earth's total mass,
which means that for all intents and
purposes, the stuff that we are made of,
the atoms and molecules in our bodies,
the food that we eat, the water that we drink, our
best friends,
has all been here since the early days
of Earth, including the air that you are breathing
right now.
Remember that six trillion
kilograms of oxygen that all humans
inhale
every year? Well, each and every one of us,
individually contributes by breathing
about 8.5 million times per year.
Here's the thing about a breath.
Because molecules
are so frustratingly small, a single
little breath contains about 10 sextillion
molecules.
In a poetic
twist of symmetry, Earth's entire
atmosphere contains a volume of air
equal to about 10 sextillion
breaths.
The number of molecules in one breath
is equal to the number of breaths our
earth has to give us,
that is assuming, of course, that we never
exhaled anything and it never got renewed,
which it does.
And because our atmosphere gets circulated so quickly
and because we breathe so often and
because molecules are so small,
statistically speaking, our atmosphere
our skinny little peel of air is
crowded with molecules that we've all
had inside our bodies
and been breathing.
To make this really mind-blowing,
let's focus only
on carbon dioxide.
We don't just breathe it in
and then right back out again.
It's a waste product that comes from all over
our bodies.
And carbon dioxide is useful to plants, which
absorb it and then turn it into sugars.
It doesn't just inertly float around our
atmosphere
forever. Okay.
Well, it has been estimated
that it takes one breath
about 1 year to thoroughly mix
throughout the hemisphere's
of earth and about 10 years to
thoroughly mix within the troposphere
that we live in
and the stratosphere above.
Now, given that only 5 percent of what we
exhale is carbon dioxide and only 20 percent of that
came from metabolism within our brain,
even if we assume that 99.99999 percent
of all the  CO2 you have ever exhaled has
been trapped in the oceans or absorbed
by plants
and made into sugars, it is still
mathematically certain,
even if you were in a brand new place
you've never breathed in before,
that every breath you take contains at
least a few molecules that were once
inside your brain.
A few of them
may have been molecules that you used
five years ago to remember where you
left your keys.
A few of them may have been inside your brain
when you first fell in love.
And
a few of them, almost certainly, were inside the brain
of your mother while she was giving birth
to you.
So,
take a deep breath because our air is
crowded with history.
And keep breathing,
because within the next 10 years it is certain that
I will breathe in a few carbon dioxide molecules that are
inside your brain right now, as you listen to me say
that:
As always,
thanks for watching.